[拍手]
これじゃあ肇社長です皆さんドッチボール行ったことはありますでしょうか
小学校の頃がめっちゃ流行ってたんですけども同じ人数ぐらいに分かれてボールを当て
て全員当てたら価値っていうゲームが dots ボールって言うそこにわかりやすく
て簡単で大人気のスポーツなんですけどもよくある企画でドッチボール100人対
100やってみたとかあるんですけどもあれ100人
一人でもいい勝負できるんじゃないか説がありまして
なぜかと言いますと100人いるトマトが大きいわけですよそんな人いるとどこに投げ
ても何か当たるような気がして
以外で宿により一人で行ったほうがいいんじゃないかという可能性が私の中であります
でをそれぞれフェアじゃないんで
100人対1人かける100機で行ってみたらどっちが強いのか今日は検証して
みようと思いますあの僕運動神経
自分に悪いですけどあの努力で何とか体力だけはあると思うので
100人のメリットとしては無限の体力チームワークのコンボトークができる
デメリットとしてはまあ10日ってか逆に100人に対して1人でやってる側は
メリットとしては的が小さい
もう全然すばしこく逃げ回ってるもなんとかなる気がしますデメリットとしては体力が
非常に有限株式会社ですそういう状況で協議
軍4であるんでいや結構わかんないと思うんですよどっちが勝つか実際にやっていこう
と思いますバイバーイこーよ
階でございます
[音楽]
多いな目の前に進めると圧巻です ok ありがとうございます
する戦力でボール投げていただいていてもすごく勉強になるので気が抜けないよってい
ません
ああああああ
がとうございます
理由からプールなんですけども
ダイヤはあれにします
me
この時点でそんな不利だと思うんですけどもまぁそれでも勝てるぐらいの自動力が来
てるのであると本音断崖やありですただ会派てでも戻れないでそれでまあ復興が築ける
ことはないんでそれでいい勝負ができるかなって思います錬磨 a 20そうですよ
頑張りますいやなし者ですはぁ
[拍手]
car
ああああああ
ああああああああ
ai
car
me
re too
ああああああ
dare
uh
car
wh
me
ああああああ
ni
いいいい
ああああああ
car
ni
うわあああああ
car
[拍手]
ええええええ
あれ受かってるまた買っているいきます
me
ああああああ
nanea
tar
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
rar
ああああああ
へいへい
amaran
rar
me
dare
ええええええ
too hard
[拍手]
me
ni
goo
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
tar
ni
[音楽]
goo
wh
car
ああああああ
goo ん
ガッハッハ
ええええええ
じゃあん
[音楽]
い k
yeah yeah
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
rar
えええええええ
[音楽]
me
teap 2
あっはぁ
ハーイね患者ないコーデキャッツで限界済ます方がわかんなくなってきましたそういう
気で検証結果
一人より100人の方が強いてくださいません